fun fact in Finland they make a fire
that's two long logs sitting on top of
each other with a wedge of wood in
between to let the air flow through well
that's your idea of fun there's it
matter of fact I have a beer I'm not
your father
oh this young man's underage so so the
laws of Texas are pretty clear on the
subject oh what a surprise there's one
more thing you know more about than
everybody else I don't know why you're
surprised I know why you're here
he's gonna stick with dr. pepper I
should get some more firewood
Georgiy thank you I'm here because my
friend George invited me uh-huh well
your friend George invited you because
he felt sorry for you
you know akane warned me you might
behave like this she she was right i
don't know why the hell she ever went
out with you well she did and we got
along famously until you broke up with
her after you got out of out of what sad
[Music]
turn my damn it'll DOMA shoot what a
Mitch
[Music]
that was some good catfish yeah real
good
gentlemen
I'm no longer enjoying this outing so
I'm going home
see it ain't gonna belt John you can't
just leave we're in the middle of
nowhere not a problem I have my compass
a place light and half a bag of gorked
no wait please let him go George
you won't tell Connor you lost your old
boyfriend in the woods well he's a grown
man for crying out loud let him do what
he wants
well that's an argument for me having a
bear shut up come on Dale do the right
thing
tell him to stay
[Music]
for a little guy is fast handy
for
you